The Joe Rogan Experience I think music
is so Transcendent it is it's my of all
the Arts I love all of the Arts and F
all of these kids who are gluing
themselves to freaking classic art
pieces yeah well the Gloom that sells
the wall and throwing soup on the
plastic someone glued themselves to the
actual painting the other day the girl
with the Pearl Earring yeah
where was this
um where where is that painting I just
was reading about it on the way they
should start hacking arms off that would
stop that I was like get bow all of them
just put a tourniquet around their
forearm uh climate protester glues his
head to girl with a pearl earrings
that's right okay oh my God I mean he
glued his head to the painter and I'm
not sure if this is true so maybe fact
check me on this Jamie but I also heard
that somebody who's funding all of these
is one of the grandchildren of the
Gettys which makes it even more
hilarious if this is true well who knows
what how much funding is involved and
crazy glue that's an oil family
yeah but I'm saying it's crazy no I know
but how much funding isn't it but
they're they're climate activists all
these people so it's just a it's a Getty
oil Fortune air has helped fund climate
activists who have targeted artworks and
museums hell it's hilarious to me you
are rich because
of oil
she looks like the person had fun that
she looks angry
maybe she's angry to be born to like
into some biohazard tattoo on her left
arm oh Christ it does say biohazard oh
my God
there's just something you see what they
did at the Porsche Museum where they
were like mad that they didn't get
Buckets to poop in no they glued
themselves to the floor so unfortunate
people just shut the lights off and left
the place [ __ ] off
I thought one of the guys was mad maybe
this was another place they couldn't go
to the bathroom yeah they wanted
somewhere to go to the bathroom look at
that glue themselves to Porsche Museum
but need to go potty staff simply left
turning off heat and lights rather than
calling the police good for you good for
you Porsha it's so [ __ ] dumb it's
like we we keep starting the
conversation like the conversation's
already happening we shouldn't even be
giving them attention honestly no it's
it's a symbol of this Tick-Tock
generation yeah it's a symptom of all
this nonsense that you're seeing
constantly online these people they're
trying to get attention with the least
amount of work possible yeah I might go
clean up a beach yeah yeah do something
productive if you care about the climate
I'm always screaming about this like get
a bunch of organize an international
clean up the beach day take pictures of
all the garbage that you collect yeah
all over the world post tick tocks about
it I could I can be an activist let me
add but do something yeah it would be it
would be really it would be moving to
see how much garbage is on the beach the
girls who threw the soup at the Van Gogh
they went on Patrick Bet David's podcast
and uh he he's a brilliant guy and he
asked them uh may I ask what your
pronouns are
and she said her pronouns are she he
they I I don't understand you don't have
to that's perfect it's perfect that's
nonsense I don't understand you're
you're she he and you're they so you're
plural you're masculine and you're
feminine you're you're basically a god
I
I don't get it though
20 years
old just want attention and they're so
happy they're getting attention because
they think they're fixing the World by
gluing themselves to the wall I would
agree except it's all been
institutionalized like people have to
put this in their corporate you know
emails that they're sending to you they
have to that like there's policy being
written in Europe about energy because
of Greta there's the it's not like oh
look at these crazy kids and they're
crazy ideas and it's somehow being
captured by their capturing institutions
well it's the the thing du jour right
it's the thing that people yeah it's the
thing that people are told they have to
concentrate on now
but there's still there's still policies
and stuff that are yes so it's still
having real life ramifications it's not
like we're like oh those crazy kids it
is having real love but but it also
there's over Corrections and then
there's balances right like there's a
guy that I want to talk to that is uh
covering Cobalt Mining and Cobalt mining
is horrific I know it is horrific and it
is in all of our Electronics it's like
one of the things that I've been saying
about all these people that are tweeting
about injustices on the world they're
doing it on a phone that was made by
slaves yeah like if you go down as far
as you can go to find like what's like
what's the source of the stuff that is
in the phone that makes it work it's
it's sourced by slavery all these
electric vehicle batteries too yeah I
mean what are we gonna do with all of
and all the technological waste what do
we we just like take computers and what
do you do their own computer well what
do you do with all there's a lot there's
a lot to do like I would imagine that
this is an opportunity for someone to
innovate and come up with a way to
recycle that stuff and use it in a way
but then I was reading about recycling
the other day I went down a rabbit hole
the other day because I was talking I
was uh reading about
um birds that are swallowing like bottle
caps and stuff like that okay it's a
giant issue yeah so then I went on a
rabbit hole of seagulls and what [ __ ]
seagulls are yeah and seagulls
swallowing rabbits and swallowing other
birds and so I seagulls are monsters no
they are they're [ __ ] monsters a
seagull on the beach out east swept down
and took my cousin's sandwich out of her
hand while she was eating it this is a
true story that's little they'll eat
your kid if your kid was small enough
they'd swallow your kid I mean they're
little opportunist monsters yeah you
know the worst is pelicans pelicans
swallow seagulls they swoop down they
take a whole seagull they look like
dinosaurs they are dinosaurs they are
whenever you're on the beach and you see
them flying by they look like
pterodactyls like little ones yeah
they're spooky animal also but they were
also also awesome so then I went down
this Rabbit Hole of recycling and did
you know that like it's it's somewhere
in the neighborhood at five percent of
plastic gets recycled even though you
say recycled yeah like you put it in
recyclable bin how much actually gets
recycled very very little of it one of
the first articles I ever read in the
New York Times magazine back when it was
good I was in high school and there was
a whole article about how recycling is
basically [ __ ] yeah it's basically
[ __ ] it's I mean it could work but
it doesn't work it could work if you
could get all the plastic and there was
some sort of a like financially feasible
way to gather it all up and process it
and reuse it it can be done right I mean
um there's that project that they're
doing with the Pacific Garbage Patch
where they're scooping up all that stuff
and they're converting it into plastic
that they use for items like you can buy
like eyeglasses that were made the
plastic frames and everything were made
with the Recycled called plastic so
you're crazy which is cool that they're
doing that and then they're actually
there's like a way to make it
financially viable but overall most of
the plastic single-use plastic like
bottles water bottles and stuff like
that it's not being recycled yeah we
stopped using water bottles here we we
just we have the water filter now and we
have these steel cups and I'm
contributing man I mean well I drove an
electric car I mean you know and that's
not providing you know it's not putting
out bad emissions but it's also it's
like where's the batteries coming from I
always think of Thomas Saul and his like
famous quote there are there aren't
Solutions there are trade-offs and if
you start evaluating everything from
that perspective you can I feel like get
to more helpful Solutions when you know
that you're evaluating the trade-offs